and you know as well as I do there's
people who like to walk alongside you so
they can say they're walking alongside
you or people who walk alongside you
because they might get something out of
it but yeah if people truly love you
they'll hold a mirror up to you and like
a therapist earlier they won't leave
they'll be there you may be with some
girlfriends you be like can you believe
this person broke up with me and they
can be like yeah because you treated
them like that and you're like me right
and so over time that's mentorship
that's iron sharpens iron and then later
on you're able to go yeah I I I can feel
myself getting hot I'm just going to let
this person my partner know I need I
need to cool off right and I think over
time yeah you you get released to the
wild that way that's just maturity
that's just growing up I think I'm way
more interested in how do I create a
life so that my alarms aren't ringing
all the time how do I create
relationships so that I can
identify a leech when I see it or I can
I can see a train wreck coming before
I'm in the middle of it